uh where are we going to go next so many
people holding it's hard to uh
it's hard to really know let's go to our
caller
from the 707 area code who's calling
today from
707. hey david this is devon
hey devon what's going on hey i'm a
really long time listener i
am in northern california i'm a 34 year
old
single father of a seven-year-old who
i'm homeschooling right now
okay and um i have one question and two
comments
okay my one question is um
you know i'm not a pessimistic kind of
person but what is the worst case
scenario for our election this year
like if trump wins and they take the
house and the senate
aren't really in some real trouble that
is the worst case scenario yeah the
worst
so the worst case scenario would be a
democrats
don't take the senate democrats lose
control of the house
trump gets himself re-elected he uh
during his next term
uh chooses replacements for clarence
thomas
and ruth bader ginsburg to the supreme
court turns his 300 or however many
judge selections into 600
and ushers in a wave of trumpism in 2022
and 2024 that it takes 20 years to
disabuse ourselves from
that's the worst case and it's pretty
bad
you know not only that but if all that
happens i just see us as like an
american people like
we're gonna fall so short to the view of
the entire world
of course like it's yeah i know and i
just i don't know how to really put it
but
you know um having being the age i'm in
i was in
a sophomore in high school when 9 11
happened and it was a pretty
impactful thing on my life but this
presidency
has really shown how far you know
we've fallen even since those times yeah
and it's just really sad
it's sad and you know the the
the us has become a laughing stock and
the pity of the world so we are a
laughingstock
but it's actually gotten so bad that in
some places they now
they're not laughing anymore they pity
us and unfortunately
you have a lot of the 60-something
million people who voted for trump
who see that as a badge of honor they're
emboldened by the fact that people in
other countries think we're out of our
minds they think that means we must be
doing something right
so i'm a distiller from northern
california we make vodka and whiskey and
stuff and i've always had to deal with
the federal government and regulations
yeah and i've always found it to
actually be a really fair system if
you're willing to deal with it and
hold up your end of the deal at this
point working with the federal
government
it just seems like they are going so far
off the deep end when it comes to steven
neuching
and policies when it comes to
immigration it's just it's almost like
um
i i don't recognize the country i live
in anymore i i'm with you
yeah and i've always wanted to like you
know save up money and go vacationing
and kind of
go around the world and tour the place a
little bit but i don't feel welcome
well yeah i mean right now it's not only
that it's also what's going on with
coronavirus but i understand that and uh
that is a
that that's a major problem and i've exp
i've told stories about that before
uh and it's so it doesn't feel good it
doesn't feel good yeah go
going into work at four in the morning
for the last 10 years um my local radio
station
kcyx would have your show on that's
listening to it and i um
have gone to youtube to watch you now
and i really appreciate everything
you're doing and the way you disseminate
information you're my favorite
kind of news personality out there and i
just have one more comment
yeah during the debate i wish joe biden
would tell trump
we're going to make america great again
that would be
interesting at the bar now yeah that'd
be amazing and i want to get a blue hat
that's seven
you know what i mean it's just it's such
a weird position to be in but
joe biden actually has the opportunity
to do it and it's just
it's a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity to
me just to change things back around and
you know i really appreciate everything
you're doing and i'm like
so excited i always call in for having
you take my calling this is the first
time
i just you're awesome man all right
devin from california thank you for the
call
great to hear from you if you love
feeding
your intellectual curiosity but you're
always struggling to find the time check
out one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an entire book
on your way home from work they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one into text or audio
that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video